motivations garbage you you only feel
motivated to do the things that are easy
lean into your passion and you've got to
really take some risks and you've got to
feel the fear and you got to do it
anyway that's the moment where you just
woke up
and so the five-second rule is a mind
trick that's all that it is
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out of the world now I started that
meant to me series to try to learn from
people who've done a lot more than us
and hopefully by being around them
hopefully some of their mindsets their
belief systems our way of thinking seeps
into us to help us become the best
version of ourselves so today we're
gonna learn from one of the best Mel
Robbins and how to change your life with
the five-second rule mentor me Mel
[Music]
you
we bought into this this complete
falsehood that at some point you're
gonna have the courage at some point
you're gonna have the confidence and
it's total [ __ ] frankly I don't I
relied to swear an absolute okay it's
it's complete garbage and so there are
so many people in the world and and and
you know you may be watching this right
now and you have these incredible ideas
and what you think is missing is
motivation and that's not true because
the way that our minds are wired and the
fact about human beings is that we are
not designed to do things that are
uncomfortable or scary or difficult our
brains are designed to protect us from
those things because our brains are
trying to keep us alive and in order to
change in order to build a business in
order to be the best parent the best
spouse to do all those things that you
know you want to do with your life with
your work with your dreams you're gonna
have to do things that are difficult
uncertain or scary which sets up this
problem for all of us you're never gonna
feel like it motivations garbage you you
only feel motivated to do the things
that are easy one night Chris have gone
to bed I've been struggling struggling
struggling we still had all the same
problems I we started lean on the house
still facing bankruptcy still fighting
like crazy I was still unemployed
he still they still hadn't figured out
like the solution yet for the business
and I was about to turn off the TV and
there on the the TV there was this
rocket launching and I thought oh my
gosh I am gonna launch myself out of bed
like a rocket ship like NASA right here
had launched me out of that bed and I'm
gonna move so fast that I don't think
hmm I'm gonna beat my brain now here's a
really interesting point I talked a lot
about your instincts and inner wisdom
and we can get into this a little bit
later but a lot of us talk about the
fact that you have a gut feeling but
what all this research that I've done
the book and and all the speaking that I
do what I've discovered that's
fascinating is actually when you set
goals when you have an intention on
something that you want to change about
your life your brain helps you what it
does is it opens up a checklist and then
your brain goes to work trying to remind
you yeah of that intention that you set
and it's really important to develop the
skill and I say that word purposefully
the skill of knowing how to hear that
inner wisdom and that intention kicking
in and leaning into it quickly so for me
my brain saying that's it right there
move as fast as a rocket Mel I wanted to
change my life and I think most people
that are miserable or that are that are
really like dying to be great and dying
to have more we want to change we want
to live a better life we want to create
more for our families we want to be
happier the the desire is there again
it's about how do you go from knowledge
to actions so the first thing in the
story that's important is realizing that
the answer was in me and my mind was
telling me pay attention I could have
also been the Bourbon anyway the next
morning the alarm goes off and I
pretended NASA was there
it's a stupidest story I literally went
five four three two one I counted out
loud and then I stood up and I'll never
forget standing there in my bedroom it
was dark it was cold it was winter in
Boston and for the first time in three
months I had beaten my habit of hitting
the snooze button I couldn't believe it
and I thought wait a minute counting
backwards that is the dumbest thing I've
ever heard in my entire life well the
next morning I used it again and it
worked the next morning I used it again
and it worked
the next morning I used it again and it
worked and then I started to notice
something really interesting there were
moments all day long all day long just
like that five-second moment in bed
where I knew knowledge what I should do
and if I didn't move within five seconds
my brain would step in and talk me out
of it every human being has a
five-second window might even be shorter
for you you have about a five second
window in which you can move from idea
to action before your brain kicks into
full gear and sabotages any change in
behavior because remember your brain is
wired to stop you from doing things that
are uncomfortable or uncertain or scary
it's your job to learn how to move from
those ideas that could change everything
into acting on them in the smallest
moment I believe that passion is another
word for energy that's it what do you
have energy for what energizes you and
that we naturally have a tremendous
amount of body wisdom about that and
that every one of us has an internal
fuel tank that is either empty or full
and if you're empty you feel depleted if
you're full you feel energized and so if
you simply are in any situation I mean
any situation and you pay attention
within five seconds to does this person
energize me do they deplete me where are
they in the scale you just gain some
tremendous wisdom and you the simple way
to start to figure out who you are and
what you want is start aligning yourself
with more things that energize you so
situationally if you're lying in bed and
the snooze alarm goes or the alarm goes
off and you feel depleted and you start
reaching for the snooze button that's a
really big sign that you need to get out
of bed now being depleted versus
energized has nothing to do with whether
or not things are hard or easy it has to
do with what naturally actually either
expands you or shrinks you and so if you
look at your client list and measure it
depleted
is energized what shrinks versus expands
me you have the actual map and when you
start to find the courage to make
decisions that energize you and that
expand you whether they're scary or not
that's when everything changes and so
that's how I actually make business
decisions is this I don't even like the
money conversation comes second it's
does this deplete or energize me and if
it depletes me how do you move it in
that direction or how do I today say no
if it energizes me how do I do more
because if you are energized or expanded
by something you will do it for no money
you will do it happily and you will
suddenly wake up and say oh my gosh like
my heart I'm pursuing my passion how did
that happen what happened one five
second alignment at a time in the right
direction so that you are actually
working with your natural wiring working
with your natural energy tapping into
your wisdom so again the five second
rule is this tool that allows you to
tune in and give you the courage this is
a tool that gives you the wisdom that
you need in order to make those
decisions and so when I get wigged out
because I don't make the New York Times
list or whatever I tune back in well
what is it that's energizing me it's not
some stupid-ass list it's that this idea
is helping people and is it your
philosophy then that by tuning in and
following what energizes you that is the
path
and if you have heard person you have
the path now you use the five seconds
I'll tell you why good you can't until
you actually learn the wisdom of you and
the power of you you can't look at the
big stuff and successfully in my mind go
get it
you'll be the kind of person that maybe
checks boxes but never feels satisfied
as you do it you're always on to the
next you're always chasing the next
because you have run right past the
number one thing that you're supposed to
figure out in your lifetime which is who
you are
and how to listen to it drive that's
this puppy right here this is what you
want this is your prefrontal cortex
Drive is the mode where you're in charge
of your thoughts okay
it's where you are fully awake you are
present and you are driving your
thoughts and actions when you're doing
that your prefrontal cortex is active
the prefrontal cortex is the part of the
brain that you need in order to learn
new behavior in order to do something
difficult in order to do something
uncertain in order to do strategic
thinking so I'm gonna give you an
example so I'm a righty if I were to try
to write with my left hand like you
Louis is gonna torture me and tie my
hand behind my back and make me like do
this I could do it it would look like I
was writing with my foot and if Louis
came up to me and said hey Mel you want
some bulletproof coffee I'd be like
Louis I'm drying I'm trying to
concentrate I can't do this my
prefrontal cortex would be el fuego
because it is firing on all cylinders to
communicate to my hand new behavior so
the thing that's cool about that is that
you can use a simple trick the moment
you feel yourself hesitate the moment
you've got one of those moments where
you know that you need to this is that
moment that Luis talks to you about
where you got to step outside of your
comfort zone and you've got to lean into
your passion and you've got to really
take some risks and you got to feel the
fear and you got to do it anyway that's
the moment where you just woke up and
now you got a decision to make are you
gonna drift back into the habits or are
you going to awaken your prefrontal
cortex and drive forward and focus and
do something new and so the five-second
rule is a mind trick that's all that it
is a fancy way to call it as a you know
it's a form of metacognition but it's
basically a hack it's a cheat code cheat
code that you're doing in your mind is
you are interrupting what are called
habit loops that get encoded in the
central part of your brain and you are
starting up the prefrontal cortex it's a
little trick that causes focus and it's
it's a lot like having a mantra because
you're shifting gears but the thing
about having a mantra is and I suppose
that as you count backwards more and
more and more
you become used to it but it becomes a
habit that triggers action so what you
do is go 5 4 3 2 1
cut off this part of the brain awaken
this part of the brain and then move and
what happens with the counting backwards
is there's nowhere to go after 1 and
your mind is socialized in a countdown
situation to go and so counting up won't
work because you can keep it over and
you do it in many aspects of your life
so it's actually not something that
requires any focus
now I've got a special Mel Robbins bonus
on why the habit of hesitation is
killing your dream but before that my
question of the day for you is I want to
know have you tried the five-second rule
or are you willing to try it I love to
hear your feedback please leave it down
in the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
what is the biggest obstacle that we
face Thiago it's simple it's self-doubt
it's not fear it's not lack of money
it's not lack of supporters it's the
fact that deep down inside you
we'll doubt yourself at critical moments
and here's the problem with self-doubt
self-doubt doesn't have to stop you
the problem is self-doubt is that the
second that you feel a little doubtful
the second that you start to question
yourself
you physically hesitate
that hesitation has become a habit that
stops you because the moment you
hesitate it wakes up your brain your
brain starts thinking and then you hold
yourself back the five-second rule is a
tool that battles self-doubt because in
those moments those those tiny micro
moments when you're faced with should I
do this or should I not should I speak
in a meeting should I hold back my ideas
should I have this tough conversation or
should I wait till later
the second you doubt the option of
moving forward
he has to
then you think that
that's how it happens every single time
that's how you sabotage your success
that's how you brought yourself joy of
hesitating the moment that you filled
out is killing your dreams
the single biggest obstacle in life data
is the doubt that you feel and the
single biggest mistake that you're
making is that you hesitate when you
feel it if you start to use the
five-second rule in those moments to
just physically move forward within five
seconds a feeling that doubt
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that mm-hmm
that people your passion can change the
way people not one drop of myself work
depends on your it's supposed to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten rows of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details